[Música]
y llegó el momento de repasar los
titulares de la prensa mundial con rosa
pérez masdéu rosa feliz jueves
bienvenida muy buen día como todos
comenzamos con los medios franceses que
titulan la condena al ex presidente
francés nicolas sarkozy como ya lo
veníamos adelantando entonces en nuestro
noticiero rosa buenos días exactamente
hemos querido ver como distintos
periódicos franceses en este caso nos
fijamos en el mont le figaro hoy el
liberación abren en sus portadas pues
con la noticia del día en francia y es
que a nicolas sarkozy ha vuelto a ser
condenado porque recordemos que en marzo
ya fue condenado ya fue el primer
presidente de la quinta república en ser
condenado a prisión en este caso por
temas de corrupción y tráfico de
influencias y en este caso ha sido por
la financiación ilegal de su campaña y
de su campaña de 2012 recordemos
mientras el mundo ha ido haciendo un
live respondiendo a preguntas de los
lectores sobre los detalles de este caso
pues él
destaca esto que al final no sirvió para
nada esta inflación esta campaña
estratosférica porque la presidencial se
la llevó el socialista françois hollande
y le figaro pues menciona que
básicamente su abogado y anunció que va
a recurrir y sé que sarkozy no estaba en
la sala que sólo ha estado un día de los
dos meses que ha durado empezamos rosa
entonces con lemon caso big mal yo
nicolas sarkozy condenado a un año de
prisión por financiación ilegal de su
campaña presidencial del año 2012 así
titula exacto raúl como decíamos pues él
le monde ha ido haciendo un live y entre
otros detalles también explicaba pues
cuáles son las condenas a los otros
acusados y si quieres raúl ya pues
pasamos al que es el siguiente tema de
siria aquí en la región porque hay un
tema final que quiero que abordemos y
aseguró rosa entonces vamos ahora con
nuestro segundo tema del día que es
ecuador la crisis carcelaria de ese país
vamos con dos medios del mercurio y el
universo destacan las portadas de la
matanza de las prisiones en este país
que además van allá si no me falla la
memoria 3 en lo que va corrido este 2021
exacto de raúl y mira nos fijamos en el
mercurio que hace pues una noticia más
factual explicando los hechos cómo va
esta identificación de cadáveres pero
por otro lado el universo si hace más
una crónica y explica como en la morgue
de guayaquil pues los familiares están
esperando ver si algunos de los presos
fallecidos pues eran precisamente esos
sus familiares incluso en la crónica
encontramos pues el testigo de una mujer
de una cabeza de familia que explica
cómo vio el cadáver de su marido en las
redes sociales y ahora sí rosa pasamos
entonces al tema gordo de revista
digital también que toca a ecuador en
cierto modo porque la investigación de
yahoo news habla como la silla planeo
acabar con julian assange esa es a raúl
a esta investigación salió a principios
de esta semana y no quería que acabara
la semana sin mencionarla en esta
sección porque es una investigación muy
extensa que cuenta con más de 30 fuentes
de funcionarios y de ex funcionarios de
la cia y de la administración trump y
que explica como sobre todo a partir de
2017 cuando wikileaks sacó unos a unos
cables unas informaciones que afectaban
directamente a la hacía pues wikileaks
se convirtió y particularmente a julian
assange en el centro de obsesión de esta
agencia y para resumir porque como
decíamos la investigación es muy extensa
les invito a que la lean porque está en
abierto pues una de las de los
escenarios era directamente secuestrarlo
porque recordamos como decías que julian
assage estuvo desde 2012 hasta 2019
refugiado en la embajada de ecuador en
londres pues bien uno de los escenarios
que contemplaba esta agencia de
inteligencia era penetrar dentro de la
embajada y secuestrarlo incluso
contemplaba que esto pudiera acabar en
una especie de tiroteos en londres entre
pues distintos servicios secretos pero
es que es una cita muy relevante que
está dentro de la investigación es que
precisamente no esto no se llevó a cabo
pues por evidentes obstáculos digamos
diplomáticos y legales no tal y como
informaron pues los asesores legales de
la casa
porque bueno esto suponía para que nos
hagamos todo es una idea o sea
secuestrar a un ciudadano australiano en
suelo británico violando la autoridad de
ecuador y uno de los presentes en una de
estas reuniones de alto nivel dijo bueno
aquí no se puede hacer lo que queramos
porque esto es reino unido no es
pakistán o egipto también esto pues es
un ejemplo bastante ilustrativo de cómo
funcionan estas agencias y por otro lado
raúl recordemos que esta investigación
es importante porque de aquí un mes
precisamente va a tener lugar en londres
el juicio en que se va a disputar este
recurso que ha impuesto eeuu sobre la
extradición de julian assange a
washington precisamente donde se le
acusa de espionaje y ya en a principios
de este año pues una jueza negó la
extradición por tema alegando temas de
salud mental de julian assange pero eeuu
ha recurrido la sentencia